mit den grössten jamaika soft gibt es
tatsächlich beim klima dazu muss man
wissen alle parteien stehen zu unseren
klimazielen theoretisch aber die
verrückten grünen nehmen die tatsächlich
ernst im gegensatz zur fdp die fdp und
das ist kein witz hätte im
koalitionsvertrag gerne die formulierung
wir wollen die klimaziele erreichen
nicht müssen stehen sie den
weltuntergang verhindern darf kein zwang
sein
fest steht deutschland wird das ziel für
2020 nämlich 40 prozent weniger co2 als
1990 spektakulär verfehlen wenn es gut
läuft wenn es richtig gut läuft schaffen
wir vielleicht 32 prozent umso
erstaunlicher was uns kurz vor der wahl
noch versprochen wurde von diesen pinken
den hosenanzug und ich sage wir werden
wege finden wie wir bis 2020 unter 40
prozent ziel einhalten das verspreche
ich ihnen und den satz wird sie bereuen
den satz winzige räume
ich sag nur mit mir wird es keine maut
geben von angela merkel vom
organisierten versprechen meine damen
und herren
wenn wir 2020 ja da dazu müsste man
da vorstellen
das verspreche ich 2020 das ist quasi
übermorgen und ohne drastische
gegenmaßnahmen sagen jetzt die weiten
nationen wird es bis zum ende des
jahrhunderts wohl sogar drei grad wärmer
so viel zum thema zwei-grad-ziel in
teilen der dritten welt sieht man die
katastrophalen folgen schon heute 97
prozent der seriösen studien auf der
ganzen welt haben nicht mehr den hauch
eines zweifels am menschen gemachten
klimawandel 100 prozent der adligen fdp
politikerinnen sehen das völlig anders
man sollte mal darüber nachdenken ob die
temperatur der ozeane möglicherweise was
mit der temperatur der sonne oder mit
der mit der aktivität der sonne
zusammenhängt wenn die sonne besonders
heiß ist dann mag das ja auch einen
einfluss auf die wassertemperatur
in meine sehen wir mal das positive
ausnahmsweise erst mal die sonne schuld
und nicht die flüchtlinge so natürlich
muss sich jeder von uns auch an die
eigene nase fassen man sollte sich
tatsächlich fragen was kann ich
persönlich tun um diese klimakatastrophe
noch aufzuhalten verzicht auf autos
verzicht auf flugreisen verzicht auf
fleisch doch die effektivste und
gleichzeitig aufsehenerregendste
maßnahme sei ein kind weniger pro
familie zu zeugen
weniger kinder zeugen
da kriegt das pariser klimaabkommen eine
völlig neue bedeutung so und
juni
die rechnung stimmt ein kind weniger und
keine angst falls sie kann kinder haben
können sie natürlich auch drei hunde
oder ein pferd einschläfern es geht
genau deutschland verfehlt seine eigenen
klimaziele deutlich aber das darf uns
natürlich nicht davon abhalten weiter in
die welt in dieser angelegenheit zu
belehren ich weiß wir sind deutsche